Hi everyone, I'm the Navy's grandson.
team of help boats google brazil and
Let's see this video some today
details that can take your ep to
next level
but what do you want with your ep and you?
Do you want money, you want fame?
I do not think we know what you mean.
would you like
also in this list of categories besides
highlights what you want is that your
season is there as a highlight in the
google play because it's here it's
a way to reach more people from
have more downloads to be more relevant
and there is a novelty now the system has
perceived that we have the year to google
collection of exclusive collections and
also located
so it's another opportunity you
who already knows the Brazilian market well
makes your ep stand out and a
reference to Brazilian debtors
first step you achieve this is that
You have to follow the grizzlies to
android platform you are seeing there
some links a part about quality
of android apps you go
to find eagles, including cases of
test to see if your ep is
also adhering to the guidelines
very important design has a design
and graphic interface that pleases the
users to be relevant because it is a
people are an era
people want to install and have
utility and of course work
is a time that works without bugs in
that the person can trust his or her
application has an important
reaching this next level is not having a
provocative visual always up to date
Let's show a point here that can
happen that can be an indication with
a face not so updated so the
people take this screen that looks like
wrong looks nothing is a screen has
a list in which the buttons of the
android operating system and
first look like this has nothing
It is different to draw attention
three dots in the corner there are who
options call - virtual
lippi compatibility issue because
is that they were developed by versions
android and needed the
menu button are supported by this
version of android but in many cases
this button has no use that either does not have a
number 1 or what do you think people
is using for example a show bar
So what do we do this?
corrected does not appear without
need is very simple in the manifesto
You'll change ownership times.
through the latest version available
android
so remember always keep the
tactical property is with the last
version available
so it will not need to display
simon of compatibility without necessity
and if you use the menu it will
display a correct time
another important point to consider
continues to design your application is the
water issue
since action bar was implemented
has also changed a little the way
classes are being arranged in a
application is then this theme here in
2.3 gingerbread screen is very expensive
he looked good at the time is a way
correct to do the classes are in the
from above but the ideal is that you now
update their waters for a new
model so it is easier to use more
easy to understand is more colorful then
which is better the user
something very important including
to use the tabs heard pg that is a
where you can change from one screen
for another side scrum farm is the
example that is here on earth including
the gmail part can not change from one
message to another, this makes it
Imagine that he would have to go back to
message list for next to next
message here only with the movement with
a gesture then he changes the conversation in the
gmail thing worth remembering is
that you can leave things a little
more animated in your application the eyes
likes to have constant feedback
things that show that you are
happening there a little glance
things that can be animated by your
window application can make transitions
transitions between
fragments when you add remove
a blatant of the screen
also can but was then working
with the alpha part of the rotation range
heard translation devils that are
present on the screen can also
the layouts make transition with some in
child is added for example a
list or a set of objects are in the
screen or even when you change from one
position of the other you drag a layout
for example making a zany animation
to emphasize that movement too
which can animate properties and values
of objects such as modifying the
color of an object make a transition
of this color change and of course some
animation how to make animations
with frames or rotations to indicate
always in motion a bone marrow that
has taken and you have feedback for it is
always cool keeping the user informed
of the activity and at the same time this
animation gives a touch of modernity to the
your app
let's go now there is a very
important information about your application in
android platform does not impose on the user
how he should hold his own phone
After all, he bought his phone.
do not you want to control how he
have to insure any correct way
to hold the phone
of course, except in very
with the games where
the orientation has to be the same
but the usual tone but an invitation may
to set up your typical
rotation the correct way which is what
you should do good first thing
Do you go to your fitness unit?
tite then put orientation keyboard
river
you can put this is that you choose
notified of changes in the
device configuration
After that, you have to deal with the change.
this setting
arriving here the method on configuration
you owe about writing what to treat
and the orientation the phone is
at that moment it's in this case here sema
is only making a post to show in
40 jumping but this point should not be
save some instance save some
object you want to use later
was even talking like holding an object
in this change
temptation when I will subscribe to the
the NGO method has in an insistent
I'll get an object I want to make
retention and place this object
return it through this method
this way then the android knows that the
object is being held in the
memory and then you can
retrieve this object
you go in a method the client chooses 20 and
will treat this object is not in the
reminding you what to do
because it always goes through the
your activity
if it is being built in the first
or rebuilt
so be careful then good
besides keeping the visual updated there the
your application is very
important to increase interaction with
its user that often it can
install in your app
forget about never coming back
so the first thing take your user
Back the app and warn of things
what's going on
notify of new authorizations of new
features or even keep
updated about your application
here we have a link where you have
showing the guide on notifications
How can you implement your
application and course leaves the basic uswitch
I have modified those that are available for
you now including putting stock
the notification then maintaining the
updated and modern application and
smooth way of the user
another way to increase this interaction
with the user is through google cloud
message or gcm which is a service that
sends messages from a server
for illegal android devices that gcm
takes care of both the back end server and the
mobile client to maintain a
data between the two
thus saving money.
battery meaning since it is not
I need each ep to take care of the
a legal example of you
using gcm is with modifications
you can warn the user with some
thing you asked for was ready and
Through the night I stayed on the ground.
knowing that it's ready and legal that this
it is free and without canopy you can use
your app's will
Also important android gives your
different forms of content from the
your application for this do India is
a very direct and simple way is that the
always have your application
available on your screen or at home
screen com is seeing here the example or
including right on the screen
blocking of the cell with the batches
media
this way even without unlocking the
phone and you can now access
relevant and relevant information from the
your application down here
we have a link that you can see the
guide how to better implement
videos with good practice recommendations and
etc
but if you already have a limit and
developed home screen is very simple is
it also works on vox widgets
for that the first thing there in the
of the category part of your
You idiot are going to cry now the category
you keep so that it can be
Unlocked until unlocked
then customize layout because the
layout is a little different for this
in this example here we put a
priest in the area you are checking
If he installs here he will use a
specific layout for what you save
not he uses is something normal and with that
you can get your index you already
developed and also transformed it into
note that it would include another
interesting is that sometimes you go
need to ask the user to create a
account or register with your service
this is sometimes not very simple because
I already have to create a new password
remember your password and use it also has no
the security is that the actual user with goal
plus this process could leave
easier to help with this check
with these advantages of using google
plus in me
the first clear is that it facilitates the login
and enter a password and enter the
wait for this new password it can give
access to the data they have already
certified with umbu and thereafter
he only uses his service with the account of the
Google
Another interesting point is to allow
users can share content
from your ep
so it works like a word of mouth
without having to invest in
marketing something else more people will
find your app and a very thing
cool is the power of the +1 button
this way users
of relevance and credibility the content
that only the ep display and so also
making it easier for people to find
Your application shows fitch is fine
interesting is the green and installs it
allows you to have a website and
use google plus also leave
on this site
when the user signs in
if he has an android device
associated with his account at that time
there in front of the computer
it will have a screen where it can
install your android app
look that cool simple yet google
places thor search for it app
will have direct the option of the installation there
so you can easily log in to the
user and life typing new passwords
and can reach marun of
installs of your application
good guys this was the video about next
web apps with some tips on how you
can improve your application and
a new level and thus achieve more
users and improve their qualification
including google play rankings
Thank you very much and see you next time.